il était venu il ya très longtemps trop
longtemps sous forme orale dans le
chanteur et le poète est de retour à la
réunion
car il ne faut plus attendre la fin du
monde est pour dimanche on peut se dire
la fin du monde est pour dimanche donc
on se dise si la fin du monde est pour
dimanche dirais que l'enfance c'est de
lundi mardin c'est la fin de
l'adolescence l'entrée dans la vie on
commence à trouver un boulot ça mercredi
on a des enfants on est mariés
le chi à la coqueluche la grand mère va
moins bien et c'est en avant ce jeudi on
commence à compter ses points retraite
vendredi c'est le début de la retraite
samedi c'est la vieillesse
dimanche parcourir le monde et puis j'ai
fait toute une partie de ma carrière
chez continent comme qu'agen une semaine
pour une vie ou comment vivre chaque
minute comme la dernière d'autres
auteurs l'ont chanté avant françois
morel le comédien le clame le déclame
avec force sur les planches
mettons la jolie nappe blanche des
fleurs coupées le vin ou frais à mon
déjeuner sous les branches ça va tomber
par où ça penche la fin du monde est
pour dimanche
il ya un tout petit message dans le
spectacle c'est plutôt essayons de
profiter de la vie et sion ne pas être
trop dur avec ceux qui nous entourent
essayons d'améliorer le monde comme on
peut à son petit niveau
et puis à 6 ont profité
de chaque instant tant qu' il ya un
texte sur le bonheur par exemple bonheur
si on a du mal à halle à le voir au
présent mais quand on garde des moments
passés on dit ah tiens voilà ça c'était
plutôt des moments heureux des bonheurs
donc essayant de trouver ces photos
aujourd'hui donc on sera content plus
tard en disant finalement c'était plutôt
un bon moment celui qu'on a passé
ensemble vraiment fait parler du temps
qui passe avec humour tendresse
absurdité et légèreté comme un certain
raymond devos c'était une référence
importante en tout cas raymond devos et
justement je trouve que des fois
aujourd'hui on on ne voit de lui que le
type qui faisait des jeux de bois
longueur de temps alors que ce qui était
magnifique c'était surtout de le voir
sur scène et de voir son engagement
qu'il avait sur scène parce que c'était
un un musicien il faisait la descente du
lait m'ont donné en accrochant ses
bretelles au bas de son pantalon et
c'était absolument politique magnifique
c'était vraiment un grand clown est un
grand homme de scène une pièce où la
musique est omniprésente mais le piano
son pianiste n'a pas pu venir à laon le
pianiste est venu et on a trouvé un
piano initialement le spectacle
fonctionne avec un piano mécanique qui
joue tout seul et moi j'avais conçu et
écrit la musique mais je n'étais pas
physiquement au plateau
et pour venir ici
il s'est avéré que c'était beaucoup trop
compliqué et long onéreux d'emmener ce
fameux piano qui marche tout seul qui
est une pièce unique on va dire et donc
du cobp à la solution la plus simple
c'était que je rejoue ma propre musique
en étant physiquement au plateau et je
me suis pas fait prier pour dire oui je
vous avouerai parce que j'aime beaucoup
ce spectacle c'est très agréable de le
rejouer puis de venir ici vous imaginez
l'inspiration c'est le regard sur la vie
mais c'est aussi le regard du
chroniqueur qui tous les vendredis matin
par le micro de france inter
et cette fois la chronique se fera de la
réunion je la fais en direct de la
réunion et donc ce qui me permettra de
me lever deux heures plus tard parce que
il ya deux heures de décalage
donc moi cette pole est
exceptionnellement je ferai ma chronique
à 10h55 heure locale
françois morel révélé au monde avec
yolande moreau dans les deschiens ne
surtout pas jouer les moralisateurs
il traverse la vie avec des gens comme
lui comme nous alors si la fin du monde
est pour dimanche l'instant présent
devient précieux et le regard des gens
de l'être tout autant